Guns are my best friends.
They're cool, they're fun,
and they've never stabbed me
in the back.
Except for that one
with the bayonet.
And for a while, the media was
focused on all the students
and activists
trying to take my friends away.
But the news cycle moves fast.
Today, we're talking so much
about Kanye,
I can barely remember how many
houses Sean Hannity has (bleep).
(laughter)
12, I think... at least.
But even if the media
has moved on,
our guns are still
being threatened.
Don't believe me?
Get a load of this.
MAN: Students across the U.S.
took to the streets once again
to protest gun violence
in this country.
The National School Walkout
came
on the 19th anniversary
of the gun massacre
at Columbine High School
in Colorado.
Outrageous!
How dare these kids walk
out of civics class
to put what they've learned
into practice?
(laughter)
This is America.
If you want change, save up
until you can afford a senator,
like everyone else.
(laughter)
Opposers, we have to defend
our number one amendment:
the second one.
That's why, once again,
I want to salute
some of our country's
"Guardians of the Guns."
-♪ ♪
-(yelling)
(cheers and applause)
Our first guardian is singer
Alishia Wolcott,
who bravely refused to perform
"The National Anthem"
at a minor league baseball game
because the stadium wouldn't let
her carry a gun on the field.
And that's a huge sacrifice.
She could have gained dozen
of new fans from that gig.
(laughter)
Besides, baseball needs guns
to stop criminals.
Do you have any idea how many
bases get stolen each year?
(laughter)
Thousands. They've even
given out awards for it.
In fact...
(voice breaking): I heard of one
man stealing someone's home.
(laughter)
And don't give me any of this
"You don't need a gun to sing
'The National Anthem'" crap.
The song is all about
the right to self-defense.
It's got bombs and rockets
and ramparts...
whatever those are.
(laughter)
I assume a kind of...
flamethrower.
I don't know.
Here's what liberals
don't understand.
It's possible to both respect
"The National Anthem,"
and make a peaceful
political statement.
See? No, Chuck, not that one.
Not that one, no, no.
There it is! Yes!
So, Alishia Wolcott, welcome
to "The Guardians of the Gun."
(gunshot, ricocheting)
Now...
(cheers and applause)
Every superhero team
has a villain,
and The Guardians of the Gun
have one
who is kicking freedom square in
the Dick's... Sporting Goods.
Following the deadly high school
shooting in Parkland, Florida,
Dick's Sporting Goods announced
it would stop selling
assault-style weapons
back in February.
Well, now the chain is
destroying all unsold inventory
across its four distribution
centers nationwide.
That includes AR-15s
and other military-style,
semi-automatic weapons.
Aah!
(crying)
They're destroying guns!
God, I feel like I'm getting
slapped in the face by Dick's.
I mean...
(laughter)
I mean, Dick's used
to be fully engorged with guns.
You know, an upright,
rock-hard defender
of the Second Amendment.
I used to be completely
satisfied by Dick's.
(laughter)
But after Parkland, the head
of Dick's got very sensitive.
(laughter)
Almost painfully so.
Now they're pulling out
of assault weapon sales
and dumping their whole load,
melting the guns down
until all that's left is a hot,
sticky liquid
and a deep sense of shame.
(laughter)
I know! It's disgusting!
And completely below the belt.
(laughter)
You know what? I'm too upset.
I need, like, ten minutes,
and then I'll be ready
to go down on Dick's again.
But for now, Dick's,
you're the villain
of the Guardians of the Guns.
-(bullet ricochets)
-(cheering, applause)
(exhales sharply)
Luckily, some brave fighters
are standing up
to corporate activism...
even when the corporate activism
isn't... actually happening.
NEWSWOMAN:
Yeti, the cooler maker,
getting heat
for cutting ties with the NRA.
It eliminated a discount
program for the NRA.
That prompted the so-called
#YetiCoolerChallenge.
Yes! Yes!
That's the kind
of level-headed reaction
-I want from gun owners.
-(laughter)
Violent revenge
on a beer cooler.
Now, Yeti has called this story
inaccurate, saying that it
"was eliminating a group of
outdated discounting" programs,
and that "the NRA wasn't
specifically targeted."
But that's not
good enough for me.
Yeti, you need
to take responsibility
for the harm you caused,
just like the NRA would do
if it was ever responsible
for something bad.
You think just because you
didn't specifically intend
(chuckles): to cause harm,
that you're somehow excused?
I call BS.
So, lady who's about to blow up
a Yeti cooler with a rifle,
welcome to
the Guardians of the Guns.
-(bullet ricochets)
-(cheering, applause)
That food tub you paid $300 for
can't hurt you anymore.
Opposers, we need to fight to
keep the Second Amendment safe,
because our guns are endangered.
They're like chimpanzees,
but they're
actually worth saving.
(laughter)
And if we let villains
like Dick's have their way
with our guns,
we'll all be totally (bleep).